هذه الأزمة الإنسانية في بيلاروسيا هي
الآن اعتداء جسدي على حدود أوروبا ،
يحاول المهاجرون الذين يعيشون في ظروف بائسة هنا شق طريقهم
بإلقاء الحجارة على حرس الحدود البولنديين
الذين يدفعون للخلف
ويدفعون بقوة إلى الوراء ، لقد
تعرضت للتو للانفجار
بخراطيم مياه يقولون لك
بدأ التوتر يتصاعد بالفعل هنا كما
ترون
على الحدود بين بيلاروسيا وبولندا ،
لديك كل هؤلاء المهاجرين غاضبون من
وضعهم يرشقون الحجارة يكسرون
الأسوار هنا على الحدود
غاضبًا من
عدم السماح لهم
في الاتحاد الأوروبي في بولندا
إذا أعطونا زهرة ، فسنقدم لهم
الدقيق ، لكن إذا أعطونا
الغاز ، فسنمنحهم الحجارة
في بعض الأحيان بدا أن العنف خرج
عن نطاق السيطرة
حيث قام المهاجرون الشباب اليائسون من دخول
أوروبا بتمزيق الحواجز في  غضب
جيد الليلة الماضية
عندما غادرنا هذا المكان ، كان
مشهدًا سلميًا ، لكن الآن تم سحب النساء والأطفال ، وبرز الشباب
الغاضبون إلى
المقدمة.  استفزاز
هذه المشاهد لجعل أوروبا تبدو ضعيفة وغير
إنسانية ،
ما حصلوا عليه كان تصعيدًا خطيرًا
على حدود دولية ، فهم
يرشقون الحجارة وأرى أن القطبين
يستجيبون بالمياه
الخارجة من خراطيم المياه التي
تغطينا بالمياه أحيانًا أن
الماء دقيق تمامًا.  نوعًا ما
من مكونات الفلفل فيه ، لذا فهو
نوع من اللسع في عينيك قليلاً ، حيث
يقومون بتحطيم الصخور على الأرض
للحصول على قطع أصغر ،
ثم يستخدمون تلك الصخور
لإلقاء خط التلميع
ولكن مهما تم التلاعب بها  لقد
كان الناس يشعرون باليأس الخام
من عدم وجود شيء نخسره ،
فنحن نكافح من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة هنا
للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، نعم ستبقى على قيد الحياة عندما
تعود ، سنذهب
اليوم إلى هنا وتعود إلى  العراق لا
لا ، لكن بعد هذه الأحداث ، قد لا يكون لديهم
خيار ، أوضحت بولندا أنها
لن تسمح لهم بالدخول إلى بيلاروسيا التي
قد تضطر إلى التراجع عن
فرصة ماثيو على حدود بولندا البيلاروسية
[موسيقى]